ma non è che devo prendere un teschio
per tutta l'isola porca [ __ ] cos'era
quella merda pervengono basta io io
smetto qui bella tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video sono fa
vj egli oggi siamo sull'high factor dove
obama mi fa i complimenti per il mio
inglese parimenti ragazzi un gioco indie
horror comedy cosa chi è questo il menù
che finoa veste dannate una figata
il menu low comando io ha già vinto sto
gioco per me comunque non così figo non
l'avevo mai visto questo è vero deve
dire perché assurdo vino su play cosa
picco spot ikea ok perfetto è partito
non so anche cosa ho più il canto di
preciso ma va bene così sono già partiti
ragazzi al prefetto perfetto siamo già
cos'è già del sacco siamo partiti allora
sono partito di là e giace del sangue a
terra spero che sia mio perché stanno
partiamo da schifo cioè vale non importa
comunque volevo dire ecco perfetto gr
grande per fantastico ma perché c'è
sangue ovunque come soggetti sobri lì
dov'è andato a finire gli stadi scusami
ma mi state chi dovrebbe essere qui però
non è qui visse a tagli e l'ultima volta
che l'ho visto era il mister ville
però non credo sia che lo stesso c'è
anche una lettera non mi piace stare qui
una donna ad una donna donna ha preso
mister teddy e l'ha portato via ha detto
che sono troppo grande per qualcosa e
stupire come giocattolo a lui non è un
giocattolo il mio migliore amico e non
posso dormire senza di lui mi voglio che
qualcuno lo riporti indietro bisogno di
lui vicino al mio letto
io non credo che tu abbia più bisogno di
lui vicino al tuo letto perché perché le
tue cose non lo so ragazzi io comunque
vado a cercare mister delli perché ha
fatto una brutta fine che mi tra l'altro
che fissa in questo cantatore dovrebbe
essere un manicomio o un ospedale uno
dei non meno capitolano ogni fotone di
sicuro non è un parco giochi avevo lol
avevo intuito chiedo penso che non gioca
un indie horror coi contro maroni quindi
mi senti l'ho trovato
l'ho già trovare lui e lui per forte
eccolo lì però ci ho messo un secondo a
trovarlo ragazzi che sono un
investigatore fantastico dove dopo che è
perfetto di qua lo metto qui il mister
da allora mister derby è già tornato al
suo posto
cosa non ha fatto in tempo a far due
passi e giace un caricamento meraviglio
e cos'è diventato buio che ha spento gli
strategici di stat è dire sei tu che hai
spento le luci l'unico maledetto
c'è massimo le posto di prima con luci
spente un altro posto
questa cosa non l'ho capita fermi un
attimo c'è una forza c'è l'uscita non è
un'uscita far milan dove sta spaccando
la spesa un attimo non ho capito dove
siamo fini acquista ha portato che sarà
ok caffè questa portata dove sono
arrivato credo no si è così c'hai
garibaldi parlato anche mi sono
ritrovato e non è possibile legame non
importanti va avanti di qualche meglio
comunque cosa cos'è starò un teschio
gaza 21 fosse fermo ma dell estro sattar
appoggia buongiorno una lavata di denti
la mattina no ok grazie è sparito che
capirai sparito un tizio non ho capito
nemmeno chi e chi buffalo [ __ ] che
devono rompere dov'è andato è sparito e
spende non ama la gente arriva e
sparisce in due secondi che lo sto gioco
mi piace seriamente ragazzino che cazzo
sta succedendo
c'è un tizio brutto ma è brutto proprio
cella ed ero io ero io questo spinato
non lo so bene che io non sto capendo
c'è un teschio
guai a te se mi spunta qualcuno mica ti
arriva una pedata ma che cazzo sperano
eroi ero io che ho spento del camino o
spento le luci nome nessuno molto
accorto fantastico e mamma di preciso
che cosa me la devo fare gli stock di
un'altra nota lui diventa pazzo se non
sono bellissima e ha detto che la mia
testa è così piccola e bella
ho iniziato a sanguinare cosa pensavo
fosse qualcuno dalla porta ho perso la
nota hanno finito di leggere la
fantastica comunque non c'è non c'è
nessuno verrano primi però ci fosse
qualcuno merda non sapevo se uno non è
che sono pazzo quando vedo le cose è
sparito la gente mi segue poi la ragazza
ed usciamo di qua perché già non mi sta
piacendo questo gioco si chiama life
after resto cioè che cosa c'è dopo la
vita insomma c'è questo schifo si
dovrebbe essere questo schifo dopo la
via grazie mille e adesso
vedova di morire proprio dove dovrei
andare di preciso che non ho ancora
capito di qua premesso si può salve
vuole che io sia bellissima è quello di
prima addome ho capito dove tra il
teschio paura di farlo in una maniera
incredibile allora fermin attimo
ok non messa che ben sei bellissima
buonasera tutte ragazze ma non trovate
che lei sia bellissima creato una top
model con megan fox cia un'invidia
pazzesca regalino sono mie sei pronto
non sono mite ma noi che devo prendere
un teschio per tutte le sue porca [ __ ]
cos'è la gola merda per gen basta io gli
ho smetto qui quanto siamo dividono me
ne frega una sega pompe che ne frega una
seria basta dopo questo può andare a
fare in culo il gioco chi l'ha creato
chi me l'ha consigliata non lo so chi me
l'ha consegnato me lo ricordo e preghi
chi mi ha consigliato che non me lo
ricordi persona finisce ma già che c'è
del sangue afferma perché io parto ma è
mio sacro perché non è possibile che
allora fatemi prendere un attimo fiato
perché succede veramente assurdo ma tipo
hello kitty robben è la più semplice no
lurida [ __ ] mi hai fatto prendere
un infarto colpa tua tra l'altro madonna
che ordini stata ragazzi camera mia e
più ordinata e ce le vuole perché non
torneremo indietro è meglio se team asta
sarà una partita feeling voce qualcosa
insieme lo facciamo perché sto annoiando
visto posto delle palme non se non ti va
a basta che lo dici non è perfetto lo
lasciamo perdere
ma neanche presente al perché sono in
sto corridoio a lui e berlusconi sorta
di telo prima no no no lui sta bruciando
però non ho capito lui chi chi è che il
tizio di prima non lo so però leggiamo
sta roba perché il mio bambino piangeva
quando dottor terra ha messo nella
scatola ma il suo pianto si è fermato
quando lei gli ha dato fuoco
tanti auguri a te oggi al dottor tarlo
odio ma perché ha fatto una festa di
compleanno così bella arias ho capito
perché pensa così stronzo con tutti
quanti perché sculetta baby rosa 22
stupisce te ne vai dalle parte ecco
perfetto bravissimo meglio i ragazzi se
ne sono andati non si sa come mai sono
stati ciaran due tizi
12 fantastico come se non basta così
capace di rompere le palle ha preso il
mio bambino si sente a posto le bambino
ti do quel tizio molto coccoloso credi
ma è sparito lega ma che belle ma che
bel bambino che c'hai ma mangia qualcosa
che le gambe sono magrissima senti un
attimo io io prendo posto grazie po
sopra grazie mille si sia anche tu sei
sexy lo porto nella stanza di prima
credo ce lo porto qua momento nella
scatola di nuovo non perché dovrei
metter no no non li dal fuoco per no ma
perché tutti insieme stavolta tanti a
caricamento a caso è adesso uno per uno
mi scrivete sotto nei commenti
qual è il senso di sta roba qual è mai
ci fosse un senso sta roba io ancora non
l'ho trovato purtroppo mi dispiace ho
continuato ad urlare per quello che
stava facendo il mio bambino ma non
importava a nessuno voleva soltanto
sentirmi mi dispiace tanto è duro però
non è che ci posso fare nulla iavi
pazienza no no no no no no no cosa c'è
scritto non posso legge non posso che
c'è un bastardo che mi segue dove sono
finiti no no no no no no aprista qua
aprista porta amico mio
apriamo sto porto e grazie raga
tana [ __ ] [ __ ] lo sapete grazie
per avermi la consegna veramente grazie
grazie infinite qualcuno comunque agazzi
mi deve spiegare il senso di quello che
ho appena giocato perché non l'ho capito
comunque va bene che io comunque
concluso più l'episodio perché ha
bisogno di una camomilla credo facciamo
due conti ragazzi se il video è piaciuto
come al solito lasciato commento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e come
non rivide la pena d'estizione solo se
nei prestiti scrivete che ci vediamo non
fossimo vito ei ragazzi